Vous savez que c’est une obligation légale d’aller à la police quand on a un cadavre sur les bras.
Si ça vous dérange pas, on pourrait l’enterrer pour de vrai ce coup-là ?
T’inquiète pas Valentine. On va essayer de bien s’en occuper pour passer à autre chose.
Normalement c’est des chrysanthèmes à un enterrement mais,
c’est pas grave, c’est l’intention qui compte.
Une fleur, c’est une fleur.
De toute façon, c’est complètement débile de s’offir les organes génitaux de plantes mortes qui rendent allergiques.
Ça sent bon
Je sais pas, j’ai pas d’odorat
Ouais, ça t’empêche pas de dire des conneries.
Arrête !
Apparues il y a des centaines de millions d'années, il existe des centaines de milliers de variétés de fleurs différentes et elles occupent aujourd'hui une place très importante dans notre société.
S'offrir des fleurs, c’est communiquer des choses.
On offre des fleurs à de nombreuse occasions,
que ce soit pour un anniversaire, une naissance, un mariage, un enterrement, pour la saint-valentin ou pour la fête des mères,
et pour de nombreuses raisons, que ce soit pour remercier, déclarer sa flamme, pour souhaiter un bon rétablissement, pour une marque d'affection, de réconfort ou encore d'encouragement.
Le marché de la fleur emploie environ 200 000 personnes dans le monde
pour en produire des millions chaque jour.
Rien qu'en France, ce marché représente 2,7 milliards d’euros.
Plusieurs études ont analysé l'impact émotionnel que le don de fleurs peut avoir sur nous.
Par exemple, la psychologue américaine Jeanette Haviland-Jones de l'Université de l'état du New Jersey,
a mis en place une expérience où des personnes dans un lieu public se voyaient offrir, sous prétexte d'une campagne de promotion,
soit un bouquet de fleurs, soit un stylo de qualité, soit rien du tout,
le tout avant qu'ils montent dans un ascenseur où attendait un complice de l'expérience.
L'étude a montré que les personnes ayant reçu un bouquet de fleurs engageaient bien plus souvent la conversation avec la personne dans l'ascenseur.
Offrir des fleurs pourrait donc être un acte social qui renforcerait ce qui fait de nous des êtres humains.
Les fleurs ont toujours joué un rôle important dans toutes les cultures et civilisations,
qu'il s'agisse des Sumériens, des Babyloniens, des Egyptiens, des Grecs et des Romains,
et même avant tout ça, à la préhistoire !
Lors des fouilles des grottes de Raqefet en Israël, une équipe de chercheurs a découvert des tombes pouvant dater de près de 14.000 ans contenant des squelettes déposés sur des lits de fleurs,
c'est le signe d'un "souci de leur bien-être après la mort".
C'est également le cas chez les animaux puisqu’on a découvert que certains oiseaux qui construisent des nids y ajoutent des fleurs pour attirer les femelles,
le choix des couleurs des fleurs aurait un effet sur le succès reproductif du mâle.
Il semblerait donc que cela soit quelque chose d'assez naturel d'attribuer une nouvelle fonction artificielle aux fleurs qui ont toujours été là autour de nous,
mais avant d'aller plus loin, même ça peut sembler être une bête question : c’est quoi la réelle fonction d’une fleur finalement ?
La fleur en fait, c’est l’organe reproducteur de la plante.
Enfin, d’une certaine catégorie de plante qu’on appelle les plantes à fleurs.
Il y a une partie mâle et une partie femelle dedans en général.
Elles sont hermaphrodytes.
La partie femelle, c’est le pistil avec l’oosphère dedans. L’équivalent de notre ovule.
Et de l’autre côté, tu as les étamines avec le pollen autour, ça c’est la partie mâle.
On pense que les fleurs sont apparues il y a environ 200 millions d’années,
et ça c’est un grand bond dans l’évolution pour les plantes,
parce qu’elles pouvaient s’appuyer sur les animaux pour disséminer leurs graines, et plus seulement sur
la gravité ou le vent comme avant, et c’est quand même vachement aléatoire quoi.
Ah oui, genre les abeilles tout ça quoi.
Voilà exactement, c’est les pollinisateurs.
C’est marrant parce qu’il y a une coévolution qui s’est mise en place entre les pollinisateurs et les plantes.
C’est à dire qu’il y a une pression de sélection des plantes sur les pollinisateurs,
c’est pour ça que tu vois que les abeilles sont poilues et les bourdons aussi.
Comme ça, ça leur permet de transporter du pollen de fleur en fleur.
Et réciproquement, il y a certaines abeilles qui voient mieux certaines couleurs comme le bleu ou le jaune,
et comme ça, elles vont mieux repérer ces fleurs-là et les féconder plus souvent.
Et du coup, la génération suivante de fleurs aura plus de fleurs de cette couleur-là, etc. C’est une pression de sélection.
C’est vraiment une coévolution.
Ta cousine est morte Valentine.
Comme je l’ai dit, les fleurs c’est de la com : nous avons attribué au fleur bien plus que la simple fonction de cadeau, elles sont porteuses de significations.
De façon générale, aujourd'hui chaque fleur a une signification précise.
Chaque fleur correspond à une émotion ou un sentiment, ces significations ayant évolué selon les cultures et les époques.
Par exemple, saviez-vous que l'amaryllis signifie la fierté, l'aubépine signifie l'espoir, et le muguet le bonheur ?
Moi non plus !
Aujourd'hui, rien que pour les roses : la rose jaune symbolise l'amitié, la blanche la pureté, et plus généralement la rouge symbolise la passion.
Apparemment, c'est un peu la même chose avec les emojis cœur, chaque couleur a une valeur.
On peut également associer plusieurs fleurs pour créer un ensemble d'émotions correspondant à une personne.
On pourra par exemple offrir à la fête de mère un bouquet de rose blanche et rose pour exprimer une tendresse sincère.
Le nombre peut aussi avoir une signification.
Pour la Saint-Valentin par exemple : une seule rose signifierait le coup de foudre, mais douze signifierait une demande en mariage.
Plus on s'offre de roses, plus l'amour est grand... à l'instar des bénéfices du commerce de la fleur.
Pas étonnant que les services de vente de fleurs en ligne mettent en avant ces notions dans leur communication pour augmenter le nombre de roses dans votre panier.
Qu’ils sont malins !
Bref tout ceci est régi par un mystérieux code maîtrisé aujourd'hui par nos fleuristes et que l'on appelle le « langage des fleurs ».
Qu’est-ce qu’il faut pas entendre comme conneries… le langage des fleurs…
- Nan mais je suis en train de tourner une vidéo...
- Nan mais c'est lol un peu...
le langage des fleurs !
Non mais vraiment je m’en fous, barre-toi, tu viendras un peu si tu veux.
Du coup, laissons une chance à ce mystérieux langage des fleurs, qu'est-ce que c'est ? Pourquoi ? D'où ça vient ?
Apparemment, ça serait né au Moyen-Orient. Il aurait été inventé par les femmes des harems ottomans au 18ème siècle,
car elles n'avaient pas la possibilité de communiquer avec l'extérieur.
Elles utilisaient donc les fleurs pour communiquer, aussi bien un sentiment amoureux ou d'amitié que de reproches,
une demande de rendez-vous ou autres.
Les fleurs servaient donc à communiquer de façon cryptée selon un code complexe.
C'est Lady Mary Wortley Montagu, aristocrate anglaise et épouse de l’ambassadeur anglais de Constantinople,
qui, ayant vécu en Turquie entre 1716 et 1718, aurait découvert ce moyen d’expression.
On lui attribue donc la diffusion de cette pratique en Angleterre plus tard.
Pour elle, tous les sentiments pouvaient s'exprimer avec des fleurs : amitié, amour, regrets, etc.
C'est à cette époque qu'en Europe, il devient très courant d'offrir des fleurs pour de nombreuses occasions.
Les hommes achetaient des bouquets pour leurs femmes ou pour celles qu'ils tentaient de séduire.
Le langage des fleurs répondait aux mœurs des anglais de l'époque, car il était difficile pour eux de montrer leurs sentiments.
C'est là que se créera une signification florale à base de guides et de sur la bonne façon de faire un bouquet et quelles fleurs offrir en fonction du sentiment que l’on souhaite exprimer.
Parmi les plus connus, on trouve celui de Charlotte Delatour, « Le langage des fleurs », avec 26 éditions entre 1819 et 1876.
Ce n'est qu'au XXe siècle dans un contexte d'industrialisation que la floriculture se développe.
L'arrangement des fleurs se développe en une profession spécialisée, et les premiers magasins de fleurs tels qu'on les connaît n'existent que depuis le siècle dernier.
C'est nos fleuristes aujourd'hui que l'on considère comme la référence en matière de langage des fleurs.
En réalité, on peut mieux comprendre ce principe de « langage des fleurs » grâce à ce que l'on appelle : la sémiotique.
Pour faire simple, la sémiotique c'est la discipline qui consiste à étudier les signes et à comprendre le processus de production de sens.
Selon l'un des pères de la sémiotique, le linguiste Ferdinand de Saussure, toute chose est ce qu'il appelle un «signifiant»,
l'objet concret que l'on doit étudier : soit un texte, une image, ou même un geste, et chaque signifiant a toujours un « signifié», un concept qui se cache derrière le signe : soit le sens qu'il va véhiculer.
Mais c'est plus compliqué que ça selon Charles Sanders Peirce, un autre père de la sémiotique,
puisqu'un même signifiant peut avoir tout un tas de signifié suivant la culture et les références de celui qui l'interprète.
Il n'y a pas deux, mais trois éléments à prendre en compte :
le signe, un interprétant et ce que ça représente pour lui.
Voir des tournesols signifiera pour beaucoup de monde que nous sommes en été,
mais de façon plus personnelle, ça nous évoquera peut-être des souvenirs agréables d'enfance,
alors que pour une abeille, ça signifiera qu'elle peut se nourrir.
Dans le cas du langage des fleurs, c'est encore différent.
Ce n'est pas une fleur plantée dans le sol qui est le signe, c'est la fleur une fois coupée et offerte en bouquet qui devient un nouveau signe.
On offre des êtres vivants morts vecteurs de significations qu'on leur a nous-même attribuées.
Offrir un tournesol à quelqu'un signifiera dans ce cas-là l'admiration qu'on lui porte.
Il y a 3 sortes de signes selon Peirce.
L'icône, qui peut être une photographie, un panneau, une silhouette,
l'indice, qui peut être la fumée qui va signifier un feu,
et le symbole, comme la fleur dans le langage des fleurs.
C'est le symbole qui est le signe le plus arbitraire puisqu'il repose sur une codification forte,
il n'y a pas de similarité comme avec les icônes et pas de proximité comme avec les indices.
Dans le cas de symboles, tout signifiant peut en principe véhiculer tout signifié.
Pour être correctement interprété, cela se base sur des conventions sociales et culturelles sur lesquelles tout le monde se met plus ou moins d'accord.
Telle fleur signifie telle émotion ou valeur.
Il est donc nécessaire de connaître un code pour comprendre la signification des fleurs,
un code qui a évolué au fur et à mesure du temps et selon les régions.
C'est la même chose que pour les langues, il s'agit d'un code établi pour signifier des choses,
c'est pour cela que l'on parle de « langage » des fleurs.
Il permet de communiquer, mais autrement.
de communiquer des émotions avec autre chose que des mots. D'où le fameux "dites-le avec des fleurs".
On peut d'ailleurs appliquer notre fameux « langage des fleurs » au schéma de la communication de Jakobson.
On a d'abord un contexte, qui est le cadre de référence dans lequel la communication se fait,
ici on a qu'à dire que c'est la Saint-Valentin.
On a un émetteur qui transmet le message, ici prenons Jean.
On a un récepteur ou dans ce cas-ci comme il s'agit d'une personne précise, un destinataire, prenons Marie.
Le message de Jean est la passion, l'amour.
On a un canal de communication, qui crée le contact entre l'émetteur et la destinataire, dans ce cas-ci un bouquet de roses rouges, et l'action de l'offrir.
Et on a un code utilisé, qui est le fameux langage des fleurs. C’est donc bien de la communication, mais est-ce que c’est vraiment un langage ?
Bon bah du coup, vas-y, viens expliquer ton truc là.
Non mais en fait, j’ai trop rien à dire.
Je m’en fous, tu as fait chier tantôt. Maintenant explique ton truc.
- Nan mais c’est pas…
- Aller, rentre dans le cadre ! On t’attend au son et à l’image, aller.
C’est relou un peu, non ?
En Sciences du langage, la première définition claire et ordonnée du mot langage justement apparaît dans le cours de linguistique générale de Ferdinand de Saussure,
l’un des livres fondateurs de la discipline qu’est la linguistique moderne.
Dans ce livre, qui ne fut pas écrit pas Saussure lui-même mais par deux de ses élèves, car le pauvre bougre était déjà mort depuis 3 ans au moment de sa publication en 1916,
on met en opposition trois concepts fondamentaux : le langage, la langue et la parole.
Le premier, celui qui nous intéresse, est défini comme une fonction biologique, inhérente à tout être humain,
c’est un peu le kit de base permettant de parler et de comprendre, d’acquérir et d’intégrer des grammaires par simple imitation lorsque vous écoutez vos parents.
Bref, le langage est essentiellement de l’ordre de la biologie et de l’inné, et c’est un socle commun à l’humanité.
Le second, le concept de langue, est distinct de celui de langage en linguistique, ce qui n’est presque jamais le cas pour le commun des mortels
qui utilisent l’un et l’autre de manière interchangeable.
La langue, c’est la démonstration du langage.
C’est un ensemble de codes partagés par communauté donnée, une institution sociale,
qui est amenée à évoluer et s’adapter à son environnement en permanence.
C’est de l’ordre de l’acquis donc.
Le français est une langue, le roumain est une langue, et la langue des signes française est une langue.
On parle alors des langues des signes, et pas de langages des signes.
Et comme nous avons chacun une façon de nous exprimer à l’oral,
et que l’acte oral est la démonstration matérielle concrète de la grammaire de la langue qui habite notre cerveau,
celui-ci est défini comme la parole.
Une langue sans parole, c’est donc une langue morte.
C’est une définition très anthropocentrée donc, qui s’applique difficilement aux cas interespèces.
Les animaux comme les oiseaux, les cétacés ou les singes connaissent-ils le langage, les langues, la parole ?
Bah vous avez deux heures. Parce que moi je suis bien incapable d’y répondre.
Mais ici, de toute façon, on parle d’un code propre à l’homme et créé par l’homme.
En partant de ce constat, le langage des fleurs n’est pas un langage,
et s’il fallait le définir par l’un de ces trois concepts saussuriens, il serait bien plus proche du terme de “langue” justement.
On pourrait même pousser la chose plus loin jusqu’à y voir un jargon.
Le langage des fleurs est propre à un groupe social défini,
souvent les fleuristes et quelques initiés,
qui sont à la fois les utilisateurs et les interprètes de ce code particulier.
Le langage des fleurs en fait relève complètement de la communication, et pas du langage,
qui sont des choses différentes bien que liées.
On n'est pas sur de la linguistique, mais comme le Créatif-là l’a déjà évoqué, on est sur de la sémiotique, de la symbolique,
et peut-être qu’une expression comme “code symbolique des fleurs” serait alors plus fidèle.
OK donc « code symbolique des fleurs ». Mais dans tous les cas, si seuls les fleuristes et quelques initiés le maîtrisent, à quoi bon en tenir compte
quand on s'offre des fleurs ? On s'en fout du coup non ?
On souhaite communiquer une émotion, et on doit passer par un traducteur, le fleuriste, pour savoir quel bouquet offrir,
bouquet qui ne sera ensuite pas compris par le destinataire dans la majorité des cas,
car personne ne va chez son fleuriste demander de retraduire un bouquet,
et même si la personne veut regarder sur internet, encore faut-il savoir le nom des fleurs qu'elle a reçue.
Bref, cette histoire de signification des fleurs n'a finalement à priori aucun sens !
Pourquoi est-ce que je fais cette vidéo, je me barre.
Non, en vrai, même si de nos jours, on s'offre des fleurs en premier lieu pour la beauté de la composition florale,
il est essentiel que cette composition fasse sens grâce au savoir-faire du fleuriste, qui est propre à une époque, une culture et un état d'esprit qui est resté.
Même si l'on ne connaît pas la signification propre à chaque fleur,
la personne qui reçoit un bouquet saura qu'elle est importante aux yeux de celui qui lui offre,
qui aura pris du plaisir à traduire ses sentiments au travers des fleurs.
Pour faire une comparaison, on parle de langage cinématographique pour la façon dont un réalisateur va construire ses plans,
ou de langage des couleurs pour un graphiste qui va concevoir une affiche adaptée à la bonne cible.
Tous ces codes ne sont pas connus du grand public, et même si on peut se renseigner sur ces domaines pour comprendre davantage ce type de créations ou même
pour créer à son tour,
ne pas connaître ces codes n'empêchent absolument pas d'apprécier un film ou d'être attiré par une affiche.
C'est pareil pour les fleurs, ne pas connaître la signification de chaque fleur n'empêche pas de prendre du plaisir à offrir ou recevoir un beau bouquet,
mais ça va évidemment beaucoup plus loin que ça.
On a parfois besoin à la fois de dire certaines choses, et de pouvoir faire comme si on ne les avait pas dites,
de les dire, mais de façon à ce qu'on puisse refuser la responsabilité de l'avoir dit.
En rhétorique, on parle notamment de ce que l'on appelle la dimension implicite du langage pour ça.
Offrir un bouquet, c’est faire parler les fleurs à sa place, et donc énoncer sans parler.
On délègue notre message à une figure symbolique pour contourner la difficulté de le dire.
C'est généralement pour transmettre une émotion plus qu'un message complexe,
et souvent parce qu'on ne veut pas, on ne peut pas, ou on ne sait pas le dire avec des mots.
C'est notamment pour ça que c'est autant associé aux enterrements dans la grande majorité des cultures, vu que la mort est un contexte… délicat.
C'est l’inaptitude du langage à traduire certains sentiments dans certains cas
qui justifie l'existence du code symbolique des fleurs,
car son approche indirecte sécurise la communication émotionnelle et en fait un code complémentaire de la langue.
Les fleurs ont toujours été quelque chose de joli, qui sent bon, planté là, sur le sol, et nous nous sommes occupés nous-même de leur attribuer une fonction,
un sens, une signification, une symbolique bien à nous.
Donc à la question « pourquoi s'offre-t-on des fleurs ?”, je dirais :
pour toutes les raisons que vous souhaitez.
Merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo, si vous l’avez appréciée, n’hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l’air,
à commenter, partager, et bien sûr à vous abonner à la chaîne du Vortex et à activer la cloche.
Et si vous voulez en parler davantage vous pouvez nous rejoindre sur le Discord du Vortex.
Au revoir.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’on n’a pas trouvé en creusant quand même.
Au moins, on aura fait une bonne action.
De quoi, d’enterrer ta cousine ou de dépolluer la planète ?
Pourquoi les gens enterrent leurs appareils ménagers dans la forêt comme ça ?
-Les gens n’ont plus de valeur.
- Y a quoi dedans ?
Nan mais on l’ouvre pas, c’est mort. Des fois qu’il y a un rat crevé, des maladies, le SRAS, j’en sais rien, t’es un ouf toi.
Nan mais je l'emmènerai à la déchetterie demain, ils sauront quoi en faire.
Ouais c’est ça, ils l’enverront dans un pays du Sud pour le valoriser, c’est bien.
Et si vous voulez qu'on continue à parler de fleurs,
et bien venez sur la ma chaine Twitch maintenant, à la sortie de cette vidéo, je suis en live en ce moment même
le lien il s'affiche juste là ou il est dans la description.
Rejoignez-moi, venez, faites-moi une fleur.
Nan, nan, nan, NAN !